Dragon Ball super didn't understand the
first thing about Goku's character thank
you so much for watching okay let's back
up a bit at the beginning of 2019 I
wrote a video entitled Goku the
misunderstood character in which I
decided to talk about the main character
of the popular TV show Dragon Ball I
guess in a way not many before me had
done it got a lot of views since then
I've released a video every single week
gained a bunch of new subscribers thanks
by the way
and I made this my full-time career
however there has been one thing that
has bothered me since right in that
video almost a year ago one thing that
has never added up quite right in my
head and that was this line from
resurrection F being too relaxed can
also be a weakness and don't even get me
started on the issues with your
overconfidence my problem with this is
that he says it as if it's obvious or
some sort of an arguable defining trait
of Goku's character and I have to say I
disagree with that assessment of Goku at
best I think it's misleading and at
worst it's wrong so what better way to
round out this terrific year then by
bringing it full circle with the
character that started it all a
character that I thought was only
misunderstood by the fans but as it
happens is also grossly misunderstood by
the very company that owns them this is
son Goku and how to--a got him wrong
before I start this I want to say that I
love Dragon Ball Dragon Ball Z and even
Dragon Ball super so if you think I'm
just some guys spewing hatred towards
the series check out this sappy
sentimental video I wrote for the series
last year when it ended ok moving on
once I finished writing last week's
episode I decided to send out a tweet
asking you guys a question
can anyone point me to instances where
Goku was overconfident before Dragon
Ball super the comments section was
interesting dozens of people began
listing circumstances like him allowing
Frieza to reach a hundred percent his
misplaced confidence and go on during
the cell games or even his decision to
fight Android 19 in the first place
comments kept pouring in touting example
after example however and unsurprisingly
a significant amount of discussion and
arguing stemmed from the various
responses to this tweet of mine largely
because I believe now having looked into
his callin Goku overconfident would be
at best a very low resolution
observation of his character allow me to
explain what I mean overconfidence as
it's defined is a belief in one's own
abilities that exceed the parameters of
reality in other words one who is
overconfident has no reason at all to be
interestingly a perfect example of this
could be observed with Vegeta who during
the cell saga allowed Sal to reach his
perfect form simply because Vegeta
believed no one could ever be as
powerful as he was a belief in his own
abilities that exceeded the realms of
reality resulting in reality hitting him
hard so how does this apply or not apply
to the story of Goku's adult life well
from my experience reading about Goku
it's true that he's naive innocent
selfish honest and tenacious but
overconfidence seems like a stretch in a
lot of ways to me let's look at some
examples for the very same reason Goku
was excited to fight Frieza while
traveling to Namak he allows Frieza to
reach max power here in this instance
Goku is aware of what he's doing what
the consequences are and he's ready to
face them in this instance he's
confident that he can defeat Frieza this
might very well have been chosen through
a selfish self-indulgent path to revenge
but he wasn't overconfident
overconfidence requires confidence that
is unwarranted
in order for Goku to be overconfident
his confidence in this scene would have
to be missed
placed and as I'm sure you're aware it
wasn't he was confident that he could
defeat Frieza and he did with relative
ease all things considered in this case
his confidence wasn't misplaced
similarly his assertion to Vegeta that
he was stronger than him in the cell
saga wasn't cockiness or overconfidence
either but a statement of fact and
observation of reality he was in fact
stronger than Vegeta during that time
but regardless above all else what Goku
really wants is to challenge himself
against the strongest opponents he can
thanks to Master Roshi's teachings in
early Dragonball he trains and fights
under the philosophy that there will
always be someone stronger around the
next corner there's a humbleness in that
mindset he doesn't presuppose that he's
invincible he expects there to be
someone better and these encounters
translate into opportunities for Goku to
always push himself to greater and
greater heights
Goku does let his guard down allowing
his opponent the best chance to defeat
him but it's inaccurate I think to say
that this is as a result of
overconfidence quite the opposite
what he lets his guard down he's not
necessarily confident that he will get
away with it because anything that would
feel like he would get away with it
would be boring to him he wants to
always ride the razor's edge of battle
pushing closer and closer to his limits
and going beyond his comfort and
confidence zone he specifically seeks
circumstances where he isn't confident
in his abilities that's where the fun is
for Goku in a fight and that's why he
said things like he's scared but also
excited the desire to test himself
against a strong opponent has always
overpowered his fear to run
this particular scene with Android 19
was yet another instance that came up
time and again in the comments section
of that tweet I sent out I'm not sure
what about this demonstrates co-could
being copier overconfident
Goku sort of chooses to fight the
Android because he's the most capable at
the time and he's the one they're after
he's also under the impression that
Vegeta will show up sooner or later as
backup as said manga in addition to this
he also doesn't know what's happening to
his body you can label him as foolish or
forgetful here but not overconfident in
these high-pressure instances he isn't
confident that he'll win but he is
confident in his abilities and that's
what he's searching for anytime he finds
himself up against tough odds he pushes
himself and doesn't quit unless
completely outmatched and even saying
that he has given up and not even
attempted to fight in some cases because
he knew he was outmatched
I do give up I've given all I've got
lord beerus but there's still no way I
can beat you for instance or if you want
an even earlier example check out this
one there's no way that we can defeat a
power like cell in a fight right now
not exactly the move you'd see from
someone who would be labeled as
overconfident however the most popular
example of Goku being overconfident in
the series within my little Twitter
thread was his decision to pit Gohan up
against perfect cell all the while
throwing a sense repeat itself to even
up the odds in his mind and what's
interesting about that specific scene
with Gohan is that Goku was technically
correct his confidence in what Gohan was
capable of wasn't misplaced what he
didn't count on was that he understood
that better than Gohan did that
particular circumstance is way more
nuanced than simple overconfidence and I
think a better word to describe that
decision is naivety naivety is described
as the lack of experience wisdom or
judgment sometimes out of innocence and
that perfectly describes this particular
misunderstanding between Gohan and Goku
and let's make no bones about this this
is Goku's flaw it's not over confidence
in himself it's that he naively
presupposes that everyone be they his
friends or his enemies treaty fight with
the same honor as he does it's for this
very reason he's constantly taken aback
during instances where his opponent
treats their
fight like anything other than a fair
contest whether it be Vegeta's sudden
decision to blow up the earth or Gohan
not wanting to go all-out in the fight
Goku is always caught off guard by
someone else's worldview in these
high-pressure circumstances allowing
cell a sense of be letting Vegeta and
Frieza go these are all examples of his
selfishness and/or naivety shining
through to label it overconfidence is
inaccurate
despite Goku and Gohan dynamic in the
cell saga we see in resurrection F isn't
talking about Goku's overconfidence in
another it's over confidence in himself
criticizing that he constantly lets his
guard down
which he does but as I explained it's
not that he is overconfident or
overestimate his abilities he lowers his
guard and doesn't go all-out because he
selfishly wants to get more out of the
fight if he thought that his opponent
was way below him and he overestimated
his own abilities he'd be bored and
that's just not how Goku operates in
resurrection F Wiest tries to
demonstrate to goku that he let his
guard down too often by punching him in
his ribs as he's walking through the
garden of beerus his planet after the
sparring session had been brought to a
close this doesn't demonstrate anything
in order for Goku to have his guard up
in this non-combative scenario he would
either need to be consciously on guard
24/7 which is impractical and exactly
the floor Vegeta has or he would need to
have ultra instinct which is the goal
wheezes training them towards so I don't
understand how this could be an
indication that he's anything other than
a weaker fired than Wiese it doesn't
demonstrate anything to further wheezes
point about him being overconfident I
mean if we really want to get into it
overconfidence is much more accurately a
trait of Vegeta's than Goku s-- he has
in the past time and again legitimately
brought about his own demise due to this
overconfidence in his abilities
I'm saying all of this while being fully
aware that akira toriyama wrote
resurrection F because this whole essay
isn't to say I think giving Goku a
shortcoming in the film was a bad idea
I actually think it's a wonderful and
interesting idea if handled correctly
characters change archetypes all the
time and for Goku to shift from a flat
arc character into a positive one is a
really fascinating development for his
character if they handle it correctly
thereafter which they didn't
as soon as resurrection have concluded
Goku shortcomings from that story
suddenly disappear never to be seen
again despite Goku paying for that
shortcoming in that very film when you
give a character a negative trait to
overcome the journey ought to be usually
centered around consequences of their
internal conflict in rejecting this
negative trait of theirs suddenly not
having it isn't development its sudden
change development is gradual not sudden
which to me is a shame because if Goku
attained ultra instinct for a genuine
growth and development reason rather
than just simply getting it it would
have given an already very cool scene
and emotional weight behind it that we
don't normally see with Goku in these
circumstances it would have made it a
very unique moment for Goku specifically
in the series and that's just it in a
nutshell
instead of Arc's flowing into each other
as consistently and cohesively as the
original series did many arcs have
beginning points and end points things
suddenly happen because plot needs to
happen and characters are given things
to work on that really if you think
about it long enough don't make a lot of
sense for the character in the entire
series the closest instance I could find
to adults Goku actually having misplaced
confidence in himself was early in the
freezer fight he never believed the
fight would be easy but he wasn't
prepared for how monstrous freezer
really was however to paint this as
overconfidence I think is a stretch and
even if you consider it full-blown
overconfidence to consider this worn
instance grounds to label Goku as a
definitive overconfident character is I
think disingenuous but at the end of the
day writing is still one of the most
difficult things when it comes to art
Dragon Ball super captured my
imagination and for that
alone I would label it a success but
just because I like and enjoy something
doesn't mean I have to turn a blind eye
instead of questioning things for me
that's one of the more fun aspects of
watching a TV show figuring out how it's
written and where it doesn't make sense
and that really was the impetus for this
entire anatomy of anime series I'm so
incredibly thankful that so many of you
have decided to share your mornings
afternoons and evenings with me over
this last year I'm truly humbled and
will continue to try my best to improve
but until then let me know what you
think about wheeshes comments towards
Goku down below do you think he's
overconfident am i right am I wrong let
me know but that will do it for this
week I've been totally not mark thank
you so much for watching
[Music]